foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
he is weak like his mother leave him
what happened that day
I stare death in the face and for the
first time I saw my true self
tell me about this Hunter
they say he uses a connection with
animals to track his prey
once you're on his list the
off the six of us and only one of you
there's six of you now
[Music]
why do you hunt my father puts evil into
the world
I take it out
[Music]
I think I think some kind of car you
were exactly like our father just
another man hunting for a trophy
the murderers
isn't that what he taught us
we don't get to do that to me anymore
Mr taglin
Mr tackling
oh where's Mr tagley oh you're standing
in him
you're a goddamn lunatic oh you just
figured that out now
thank you
there is an animal in each one of us
don't you want to know why they call me
the rhino
foreign